[Music]
along with flavor aroma and presentation
one of the key elements are lifting a
dish from the ordering tips Audrey is
texture get the two to right when you
take food to that next level of
indulgence
[Music]
my aim when I'm cooking at home during
the Christmas holidays is to make dishes
with a minimum fuss that still deliver
the wow factor my next recipe for panna
cotta ticks all the right boxes it's
easy to make and has a silky smooth
texture that makes it one of the world's
sexiest desserts
[Music]
first at 250 milliliters of cream to a
pan then pour in 50 mils of milk and add
50 grams of caster sugar the sugar in
early because it stops the milk and
cream from boiling over give that a
little stir
bring out the ball panna cotta
which means cook cream in Italian can be
flavoured with anything from vanilla to
coffee to chocolate I'm giving mine a
grown-up kick with a splash of rum in
once the cream has come to the ball take
it off the heat and add a couple of
leaves of gelatine and that'll be sowed
in cold water and squeeze dry then whisk
them in the gelatine sets the cooked
cream so want that really nice sort of
damange texture rich silky and
incredibly smooth once the gelatin has
dissolved poured a panna cotta straight
into servant glasses traditionally it's
set in moulds then turned out onto a
plate but I'm keep in mind simple leave
a little space on top for the glaze now
set them into the fridge beautiful next
the pomegranate glaze add some caster
sugar to the pan and pour in pomegranate
juice then simply bring it to the boil
and reduce it down to the consistency of
a sticky syrup
[Music]
in Iran where pomegranates originated
they used this sweet sticky syrup to
flavour chicken and game birds a
beautiful rich sticky glaze pour that
into a jar leave that to cool down take
the panna cotta from the fridge
they set dutifully and they're not too
firm just slightly bouncing it with
springy on top carefully pour the cooled
pomegranate glaze over just roll around
a little bit just to pull those edges
finally take a bar of chocolate that's
been chilled in the freezer so it's
easier to use and scrape off thin shards
almost like sort of chocolate gold leaf
and sprinkle it on top
[Music]
you